Tamara, vous avez suivi
en Russie et cet attentat,
on senququ'il ébranle toute la
classe politique dans le pays.
- Et la classe médiatique aussit
elle faisait partie cette femme,
se décrire comme journaliste
qui faisait du journalisme sle r
l'ensemble de son oeuvreurur
ses comptes à elle, ou dans les
médias russes, pour vo
était en fait une activiste
politique.
- Une militante.
- Une militant
beaucoup de ces commentateurs
en Russie,uiui travaillent au
service de l'État, faisaient
et fon
la guerre. Donc évidemment,
touseueux qui travaillent de
près ou de loin dans la machine
sous le choc aujourd'hui.
Vous savez, c'est des gens quivs
la quiétude depuis le début
de la guerre... depuis le début
de la guerre, à l'a
et qui se rend compte
aujourd'hui que êême dans
la quiétude de Moscou, même
à des centa
du Front, ils peuvent être soit
ciblésrcrce qu'on sait pas qui
est à l'origine, ou encore être
sa
gouvernement. Parce que ça c'est
unune des thèses qui est explore
aujourd'hui pour expliquer
- Oui, bien justement,
parlez-nous de ces thèses, là,
partout. Parce que qui avait
vraiment intérêt selon vous,
à faire disparaître cette
- À première vue, peononne et
c'est cru le dire comme ça,
étant donné que c'est
dramatique ce qui s'est passé,
c'est qu'elle n'aiait pas
de valeur particulière, pas plus
que son p
Douguine. Même si on dit
qu'il était un allié de Vladimir
Poutine. C'est pas des gens
qui étaient indispensables au
Russes aujourd'hui, qui étaient
ces deux-là, je suis prête
à parier que la majorité ne le
savent pas. Donc qui a intérêt?
et ça dépend comment on se sert
de l'assassinat pourépépondre
à cette question. Le FSB,
la Russie, accus
On dit, preuve à l'appui :
"Ça y est,n n a fait l'enquête.t
extraordinaire, en moins de h,h,
on a identifié une Ukrainienne,
on dit, c'est elle qui,
télécommandée par Kiev,
a perpétrer l'attent."."
On a publié sa photo, on dit
qu'elle s'est
les pays baltes. C'est assez
boiteux, par q qu'on n'a pas
toutes les preuves pour
justifie
Et encore une fois, quelle est
l'inrrêt de l'Ukraine de faire
disparaître cette jeune femme,
L'autre thèse est une
possibilité très certainement,
c'est un groupe d'opposition
souterra
déstabiliser le régime
et envoyer un message de façon
très brutale. C'est pas
impossible. D'ailleurs, il y a
républicaine nationale
de Russie, qui a publié
un manifeste pour revendiquer
l'attentat. Mais encore là, on a
dernière thèse est celle qui est
beaucoup discutée aujourd'hui,
ça s
Kremlin ait orchestré lui-même,
cet attentat. Pourquoi? D'abord
du modus operandi, souvent en
Russie, mais aussi pour envoyer
s'apprête à souligner les six
mois du début de l'invasion,
alors que l'Ukrain
à célébrer. Ça, c'est très
symbolique : 3anans
d'indépendance,
en pleine
- Mercredi.
- Mercredi, se donner encore
une fois une justificationsisis.
Parce que regardez comment
Vladimir Poutine...
- Ce serait un prétexte?CCCCCCÇ,
quoique Vladimir Poutine n'a p
besoin de prétexte, il mène
cette guerre déjà depuis six
il va tenir, Monsieur Poutine,
une cérémonie pour ldédécorer,
Daria Douguina, de la médaille
du courage. Ça, c'est la plus
président peut offrir en Russie.
On va en faire une martyre.
Et
qui est peut-être fatigué de
cette guerre, avec les sanctions
et avec ce que ça amène en
Russie comme nouvelle réalité,
et se demander : "Est-ce qu'on
n'a pas raison de continuer
et même d'intensifier
- Donc ça pourrait avoirun impas
de la guerre en ce moment.
- Absolument., , , , , , , , , .
On va se reparler cette semaine
donc de ceananniversaire,
de ce jour de l'indépendance
en Ukraine et de ces six mois
aussd d d d d d d d d d d d d d.
- Beaucoup de villes sont sur
unun pied d'alerte, interrompt
les services de métro, vont
prolonger les couvre-feux,
des attaques peut-être
plus violentes que d'habitude.
- Merci Tamara, au revoir.